hello and welcome to the agenda products
sold or bought in the EU have to abide
by safety standards but recently there's
been a twenty-six percent increase in
dangerous products especially is more
and more of a shop online new changes
are on the cars to tighten up rules to
restore consumer confidence get business
booming and snap out rogue trading the
internal market committee votes on the
draft report on product safety on
Thursday set up after the financial
crisis the European globalization fund
to help people made redundant find new
jobs criticized have been too slow in
providing help it faced the axe with
funding now back on the table member
states wants to fund apply to those on
temporary short-term or self-employed
contracts the employment committee will
vote to adopt the agreement reached with
member states on Thursday the EU wants
to break the glass ceiling and get more
and more women on the board room or big
companies the goals to get
representation up to thirty percent by
2015 and forty percent by 2024 with
eighty-five percent of men holding the
top jobs and so far only 24 companies
signing a pledge to end inequality
reaching those goals could be tough
Parliament's women's rights committee is
set to vote on the draft report on
Monday a month after launch it's time
for citizens to react as Paris plays
host an exchange of ideas on tackling
and employment with some 26 million
people without jobs in Europe what fresh
ideas do we have watch the debate live
with mep provence perez economists and
entrepreneurs on YouTube on Tuesday and
that's all we have for this agenda take
care and enjoy the week